[Music]
here at five o'clock the i-team with new
information about the fire that killed
former zappos ceo and entrepreneur
tony shea now investigators releasing
brand new details and video tonight
the i-team's david charns has been
following the story and the
investigation
since the november fire he's live in the
newsroom now with information first
reported on our 8 news now app
david and denise investigators say that
fire that killed tony shea was burning
for 10 minutes before the first
911 investigators saying today shea was
sleeping in a shed with a propane tank
blanket
and candles
calls made outside the shed former
zappos ceo tony shea was in
reveal a chaotic scene i'm not getting a
response from him
we're not getting a response okay who is
he
i'm his name pictures showing the
charred remains of pool equipment
and a blanket covered in soot
investigators say the fire had been
burning for 10 minutes before that first
call
but investigators don't know if it was
intentional
retreated to the shed after a fight with
his girlfriend a long time zappos
employee
investigators say shea was using a
propane heater to stay warm and
also lit candles the temperature outside
34 degrees there was also evidence shea
was intoxicated or impaired
possibly from whip it nitrous oxide
containers found around him
documents revealing an employee was
checking on shea every 10 minutes
and hours before a candle had burned
shea's blanket
fire investigators aren't sure what
started the fire that eventually killed
shea
but say the entrepreneur liked candles
the interviews with
the witnesses said that
tony does enjoy candles
and that's been well reported it reminds
him of a simpler time in his life
is what the common trend or
on the answers to that was now the
i-team also learning today shea was
traveling with the nurse
who was actually staying at a nearby
hotel investigators are still waiting
for toxicology results but say that
likely won't change the cause of the
fire which they have ruled right now is
undetermined when i asked today if there
was any evidence that shea tried to
escape that shed
investigators simply said they didn't
know live in the newsroom i'm david
charns 8 news now
david thanks for that that update the
i-team was actually the first to report
these new details on our 8newsnow.com
along with inside of our app
right now online you can look at the
timeline of events leading up to the
fire
plus all of the new videos and photos
that were just released today
the 8 news now app is free and you can
find it in the app store